a bustling afternoon in central Tel Aviv
was brought into chaos as a car rammed
into a bus stop
then the suspect got out and began to
stare at those who weren't injured
a passerby then shot him dead Israeli
police identified him as Hussein Halala
from Samu near Hebron in the occupied
West Bank on the scene medical workers
gave a statement
eight uh victims of this
one in critical condition two in
moderate condition and the rest either a
reminder injuries or stress reaction and
uh
the far right national security minister
also arrived on the scene and spoke of
the need for Israelis to arm themselves
this citizen saved lives this is our
policy at the ministry of National
Security to give people weapons to
defend themselves we can't put policemen
on every street but we can give
civilians weapons to defend themselves
I call on Israeli citizens carry guns
our ministry's policy is to make it
easier as possible to get gun licenses
weapons save lives Hamas which runs Gaza
quickly reacted praising the attack but
not claiming direct responsibility they
said that the heroic operation in Tel
Aviv is the initial response to the
occupation's crimes against our people
in the Janine camp
although Hamas didn't take any
responsibility for this attack it likely
won't be the last and as we've seen in
past incidents defending Israelis from
Individual attacks like this is next to
Impossible Imran Khan Al Jazeera West
Jerusalem